Bioelectricity wow gotta be
honest a little jealous hey
look i got nothing on the og think we should
run test tomorrow a little voltage analysis oh
man yeah sorry i've been meaning to tell you
i'm not gonna be around for the next few weeks
is this some kind of b joke i don't get no
uh mj's headed overseas for the bugle and
requested me as her photographer kind
of a working vacation for us oh man
look i don't know if i'm ready to fly
solo i screwed up today big time with
the helicopter but then you delivered big
time you saved my bacon miles i got lucky
hey i did this gig for eight years
without backup and you better believe
i screwed up lots of times but that is how you
learn what's this christmas present but first
you gotta take the oath oh um okay i promise to
do everything in my power to protect this city
i promise that's it
that oath a real thing totally definitely didn't
just make it up see in a few weeks spider-man
new york's only spider-man
i'm new york's only spider-man
look i don't know if i'm ready to fly solo
you've got to take the oath i promise to do
everything in my power to
protect this city i promise
guys i wanted to thank you both of you
you need to lay low don't trust anybody
and don't take off that mask this message
will stop it they need you
miles what's the underground doing
they're after new form tinkerer stop
gotta say i'm disappointed but krieger
every time i think i got this spider-man
thing figured out something goes wrong
our family doesn't give up whenever you say
spider-man you always mean the other one
you're spider-man you can fix this your way
this is my time for the time's gone it's scary
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new spiderman miles morales trailer video
obviously this week is crazy because they're
shipping out xbox series x's and ps5 hopefully
you guys were able to snatch a pre-order but in
honor of the big event i am giving away copies
of this game all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your favorite
spider-man video game on the video i have
had a chance to play the game a little bit
so in addition to talking about the trailer
footage and what's going on during the game
itself i will do a bit of a non-spoilery review
also explain what's going on with bodega cat
here that's wearing the spider-man mask but
it is every bit as solid as spider-man ps4
but this isn't meant to be the full spider-man
ps5 launch game this is sort of like a side
adventure as that clip at the beginning sort of
tells you there's a very important reason why
peter mains spider-man is not in new york city
during the events of spider-man miles morales
when everyone saw that in the earlier footage
there were all kinds of theories oh maybe
he's actually not here because he's over in san
francisco in the marvel avengers game a version
of spider-man is going to show up during that
game but it's obviously not this spider-man ps4
version of the character as he says he's going
to europe to help mary jane with an assignment
so hopefully that explains where this fits in
the timeline after the events of spider-man ps4
a little bit of time has gone by it's the holidays
now they're obviously releasing it in real life
during the holiday period but it really just takes
place over the holidays itself so peter comes back
at the end of that and then that's when the events
of spider-man ps5 the full version of spider-man
ps5 will take place once they eventually release
that game and then obviously because this is a
miles morales game you have a bunch of different
versions of the suit and a bunch of spider-verse
easter eggs so if you're a big fan of spider-man
into the spider-verse one of the best spider-man
movies of all time not just a good animated movie
you do have a chance to get that suit from the
movie the spider-verse movie at the beginning
when you first buy the game most of the way the
game works the mechanics the button layout is very
similar if not exactly the same as spider-man ps4
so if you've been playing spider-man ps4 for the
past couple of years since that game came out then
it'll be a pretty seamless transition for you
but they were also able to improve on some of
the things from spider-man ps4 so one of those is
the side missions themselves so the side missions
during miles morales are way more fun to do and
they're not so much of a slog as they were during
spider-man ps4 miles comes back to harlem to stay
with his mother during the holidays so that's why
most of the game takes place in and around the
harlem area also it's sort of a metaphor for
the way spider-man ps5 is going to be sort of
like a side adventure inside this neighborhood
specific to miles morales they go way deep on his
character there's all kinds of little easter eggs
that you can find little time capsules that give
you details on his own backstory and his life with
his family growing up for the most part the main
antagonists are both roxan's corporate interests
trying to gentrify the neighborhood basically
the corporation taking over the area but also
the purples in the tinker the purples as you would
expect are the people that look purple working for
the tinker with that special energy they also show
you aaron davis miles's uncle for the first time
during this the prowler he looks a little bit
different from the version in spider-man into
the spider-verse everyone's just a little more
influenced by technology during the spider-man ps4
games but if you've been seeing a lot of the other
outlets give this rave reviews really top scores
it's well earned it's a solid game just like
spider-man ps4 was obviously it's from the same
people same quality you would expect so if you're
a really big fan of the miles morales character
i know everyone wants to see him show up in
live action in the mcu he is actually already
a character marvel has confirmed that he exists
within the world of the tom holland spider-man
films it's just that when we heard about him
in spider-man homecoming for the first time he
was a really little kid so it was a long ways
off from actually ever getting the spider bite
and becoming a version of ultimate spider-man
in fact donald glover's character aaron davis
their version of the prowler in the mcu at least
or before he becomes the prowler actually had
a deleted scene where he literally calls him on
the phone and talks to him saying his name miles
excuse me
a human being needs help
he just do man yeah sorry miles i'm not gonna
make it yeah i'm just stuck after spider-man
far from home one of my favorite theories is that
he actually didn't get snapped so miles morales
is now five years older and just way closer to
becoming a version of spider-man but still a
little ways off what would probably happen first
is that marvel would just bring that easter egg
back around and you would see an actual version
of miles that's just a little bit older but hasn't
got the spider bite yet and then they would tease
that in some sort of post-credits scene so they
can deal with it either in his own spin-off
movie or a future tom hall in spider-man film
we've already heard so much stuff that's
going into spider-man 3 there's so many
rumors about them doing spider-verse easter eggs
i think it's only a matter of time before they
eventually get to miles morales but i'm not
expecting a ton from him during spider-man 3.
and for those of you that are asking about
spider-man into the spider-verse 2 the animated
movie sony is in the middle of making that
right now it's supposed to come out in 2022
there's definitely a lot of easter eggs for
spider-man into the spider-verse during the
video game but one of the other cool things
that's happening during this is obviously it's
an older version of miles morales that's using
his powers in a much deeper way than we've seen
during the first spider-man into the spider-verse
movie because miles is so much younger during that
so when you're playing the game you just have
to imagine a version of either live-action miles
morales or spider-man into the spider-verse
2 miles morales using his abilities this way
the whole deal with the cat that you saw in the
earlier trailers is you actually have a chance
to rescue it earlier in the game and then
later use it as an added pet attack so if
you've ever used pets during your attacks
like in mmos it's the same type of thing
it's just meant to be a fun added bonus you don't
absolutely have to use it to complete the game
but what will happen is because i'll be doing a
bunch of marvel videos the next couple of weeks as
i'll just remind people about the giveaway during
the marvel videos so that'll be open for a while
no worries everyone let me know in the comments
what you're most hyped up about and leave all your
video requests on the comments below i don't have
a lot of plans for a bunch of gameplay videos or
anything like that but i will think about it
sony told us that we're supposed to get some
sort of spider-man 3 movie teaser before the
end of the year we'll probably get a venom 2
trailer probably another morbius trailer sometime
by january and we have new marvel Wandavision
episodes coming in december as far as we know so
there's a bunch of big marvel stuff and a bunch of
big spider-man stuff happening in the next couple
of months so it's going to be really cool but i'm
also in the middle of doing the mandalorian season
2 episodes so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those when they
post while you wait for everything click here for
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 2 video
and click here for that brand new spider-man 3
tom holland clip thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!